-Guys, it is time for
"Bad Signs."
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Bad signs ♪
-"Bad Signs" is filmed
before a live studio audience.
[ Laughter ]
-These are pictures of
funny or weird signs
that you guys saw
and sent into us.
And these are all real.
This first one was sent in by
Matt Zaleck in Phoenix, Arizona.
It's a sign for a new restaurant
that he spotted.
Let's see what it said.
It's called Just Tacos and More.
[ Laughter ]
That's it.
-That's all you got?
You got tacos?
-We got burgers too.
You got pizza.
-Oh, okay.
-Whatever you want.
-Do you have sushi?
-Just tacos.
You heard me the first time,
right?
-Sushi?
-Yeah, of course we have sushi.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This next one is from Patrick
Bender in Bayonne, New Jersey.
Hey.
-Hey.
-He was shopping at Rite Aid
and spotted this amazing deal.
Look at this.
"Buy zero, get zero
at zero percent off."
[ Laughter ]
Sold!
-Where do I sign?
-That's a deal.
This next one was sent in by
Bradley Nell in Dallas, Texas.
He was shopping in a department
store and saw this sign.
"For your convenience, an
elevator is located in China."
[ Laughter ]
So simple.
-Oh, what do you do?
-Go to the airport, it's
an international flight,
so you got to go a couple hours
ahead of time,
and go all the way to China and
then you can take the elevator.
-Oh, my God.
-Very convenient.
This next one is sent in
from Kate Van Perren in Georgia.
She was out to eat with her kids
and spotted this great offer.
"Your favorite kids eat free
on Sundays."
[ Laughter ]
"Not so fast. You can go."
-"You can go to Just Tacos."
-"You can go to Just Tacos.
There's more.
They have more than just tacos."
This next one is from Austin
Haven in Grand Rapids, Michigan.
He was vacationing in Australia
and spotted this sign on a tram
he was about to get on.
It says...
"Touching wires causes
instant death.
$200 fine."
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to pay that $200.
-Good luck collecting.
-Yeah.
-This next one was sent in by
Rainer from Dresden, Germany.
He was eating at a restaurant
and went to use the bathroom
and he saw a social-distancing
sign telling you where to stand.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
For Spider-Man, maybe.
-Yeah.
-Next one was sent in by Judd
Kirk in Yorba Linda, California.
It's a new business
that he spotted
in a strip mall near his house.
It says, "pediatric tattoos."
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Kids are getting into it.
Yeah. They love it.
-Only for your favorite kids.
-Oh, yeah.
This next one was sent in
by Josh Marchant in Utah.
He was visiting a park
and saw this sign.
Look at this.
"Please do not sit on fence."
[ Laughter ]
-Ouch!
-How could you possibly sit
on that fence?
[ Laughter ]
-Look at those curved blades.
-It's almost like a fish hook.
It's a cruel fence.
This next one was sent in
by Howard Tanner
in Adrian, Michigan.
He was shopping in a pharmacy
and spotted this sign
right here.
"Fun gift ideas."
Let's see what they had.
It's a bowl of Vaseline.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
For the people who want to
sit on the fence.
-Oh, yeah.
Finally, this last one was
from Michaela Strausba
in Indianapolis, Indiana.
She spotted it while driving.
The place is called
Beautiful Beginnings.
"Closing sale."
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
That's all the time we have
for "Bad Signs."
If you see a funny sign,
e-mail it to us at
badsigns@tonightshow.com.
We might put it on the show.